[Music]
i always just did whatever i wanted
because i was young and i didn't care
you're gonna have to promise me
something what
she won't call the cops
uh hello miss carlisle mrs
ben saunders gardener extraordinaire
ready to get started
hey ben
something i can do for you mrs carlisle
thank you you know how you could like
really really think me
mind if i jump in the pool are you a
swimmer i never really get the chance
but i'm pretty good at most physical
stuff
she's a little out of your league don't
you think here's some advice all things
in this world are divided into groups do
not mix your groups
look i don't have anything and i see
your house and your car you have all
these beautiful things and they aren't
being taken care of you have no idea
what it means to a guy like me to take a
dip in a private pool
i'm in love with you
it's all a game
the whole world
i'd like to report an illegal alien in
my neighborhood
only suckers choose not to play
you like her you want her
you want me to cut her so she bleeds all
over she makes no difference to me
you want something that doesn't belong
to it you
kind of overstay my welcome maybe you
should go do you want me to
[Music]
[Music]
you